everyone and welcome to this
extraordinary meeting of the council
before we commence this meeting i would
like to ask everyone to stand and join
me in a minute silence to pay tribute to
sir david amis mp who died so tragically
on friday southern his constituency
and if i could just
make the note that
for the duration of the meeting
we can all remain seated
so may i first of all remind you of some
domestic arrangements
the toilets are situated outside the
meeting room opposite the stairs
cold water is also available in the
breakout area outside the meeting room
if the fire alarm should sound please
leave the building
sorry leave the meeting room by the
following far exit signs and meet on the
ipswich town football club training
pitch
do not re-enter the building until you
are told it is safe to do so
uh please switch off all mobile phones
or return them to silent
uh i would like to remind everyone
present that this meeting will be
broadcast live to the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are comfort
confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to be filmed
by entering this meeting you are also
consenting to being filmed by the
council and to the possible use of those
images and sound recordings for
webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
and before i move on to the agenda i'd
like to welcome the
usual cohort of officers um and just to
note
that
cathy nixon is standing in the place of
arthur schinovia
and jan robinson is standing in in place
of our monitoring officer emily ewell
who is not well and we wish a speedy
recovery
and finally i'd like to welcome nadim
who is our new assistant director of
communities and well-being and i believe
this is his first council meeting
welcome
can i move to agenda now please
so apologies for absence
thank you chair i've received apologies
for absence from councillors hattingham
councillor humphreys and councillor
phillips are there any more please
okay
so to item number two declaration of
interest by councillors are there any
declarations of interest
no okay then we will move on to item
three which is motions on notice
um so we have two motions on notice this
evening
um
and we're going to move to the first one
um
from councillor pratt and uh
i would like to call
on councillor pratt to move
his motion and uh councilor perhaps you
have five minutes to do so
thank you very much chair and uh it's a
pleasure to be introducing this motion
again um
so um starry skies inspire or and wonder
uh they are a magical sight that bring
stargazers and astronomers astronomers
into the dark locations in our
countryside to seek their connection
with the cosmos
light pollution however presents
prevents us from observing
the night sky
it is the result of artificial lighting
at night
particularly the lighting that shines or
scatters upwards into the sky producing
what is known as sky glow over our towns
sky glow reduces our ability to see
celestial objects that would otherwise
easily be seen
in the contrasting backdrop of darkness
in some places
artificial lighting essentially turns
night into day
street lighting is no longer only a
feature of urban landscapes with new
development and changes in the way we
use the countryside our villages and
open country are becoming more brightly
lit
climate change alongside other
environmental and economic concerns have
led to the replacement of conventional
lighting such as high pressure sodium
lamps with leds that are more energy
efficient
in addition to producing an intensely
bright light nearly all leds emit higher
levels of light within the blue region
of the light spectrum than their
traditional counterparts
increased light intensity
and the shift in spectral composition
towards blue light has impacted wildlife
particularly bats and nocturnal insect
population it can also cause harm to
human health and well-being too
lighting can improve the feeling of
safety for drivers and pedestrians
but there are also negative human
impacts to consider studies suggest that
direct exposure to light at night can
have serious health implications it can
particularly affect our bodies hormones
that are responsible for maintaining
sleep patterns there is also evidence
which presents a direct link to the
development of known cancers including
thyroid cancer
light entering private households can
also be seen as a public nuisance
we understand that biodiversity is in
peril
some estimates predict that one million
species or 40 percent of all insects
will become extinct over the next few
decades peer-reviewed studies
demonstrate how artificial light at
night has contributed significantly to
insect declines this is because
illumination not only causes
disorientation in insects but affects
their natural biological rhythms
of that
control that that control foraging
migration and reproduction
that are normally synchronized with
daily monthly or yearly light cycles
this has catastrophic implications for
insect populations studies have also
shown that artificial lighting at night
are extremely disturbing to bats because
bats avoid light and change their
foraging path and delay their emergent
from their roosts
missing the peak time of insect
abundances when they should be hunting
taken together we must acknowledge the
impact the lighting has had on human
health and the environment
in our july 2019 meeting
mid-suffolk district council
acknowledged the accelerating rate of
species extinction by declaring a
biodiversity emergency
we pledged to bring forward proposals
and take actions to protect and enhance
wildlife in the district
to achieve this goal we cannot ignore
the need to mitigate insect declines in
relation to artificial lighting as well
conveniently leds can be engineered to
emit lower levels of blue light using
colour filters in particular we could
look into using true amber or phosphor
converted amber leds brightness can also
be reduced remotely and progressively
dimmed
lamps can also be timer and sensor
controlled
name which means that they come on for
shorter periods or only when needed and
shields or battles can be fitted to
reduce sky glow and prevent light from
entering households
other councils are already taking action
to reduce the impacts of lighting
especially in wildlife centres sensitive
areas for example worcestershire county
council installed bat-friendly lighting
along an a-road nearby a local nature
reserve the street lights are designed
using colour filters especially to emit
light that does not affect the natural
sensors and rhythms of bats
yet which provides enough illumination
for residents helping to make the roads
and pavements safer while being highly
energy efficient
okay
today i urge councillors to acknowledge
the detrimental impact of artificial
illumination at night on human health
and nocturnal wildlife our council can
take action to ensure lighting schemes
on all new developments meet the best
environmental standards
through appropriate recommendations and
requirements in our biodiversity spd
where practical we can apply title
controls on outdoor lighting in our own
buildings housing stock and public realm
we must also work with our partners at
county council and highway division and
private landowners and companies
to change the way they use outdoor
lighting at night i'm just going to wrap
it up
through campaigning we can also
encourage
the public to reduce their impact by
doing so we show that we are a council
that is adaptable in the face of
emerging issues and an ever-changing
world i invite you to support this
motion and as far as i know become the
second council in suffolk to commit to
reducing light pollution thank you
thank you councillor could i have a
second at least
councillor fleming
i'm happy to second um the motion thank
you
would you like me to speak now or later
you can speak now if you wish or you can
reserve your right to speak um i'll
speak now then thank you
good evening everybody
i'm very happy to second this motion
which is about the control of light
pollution as my colleague across the
floor has said
and the purpose of this motion is to
draw attention to the largely unintended
effects of artificial light particularly
given that we have made such um
firm commitments to protecting and
enhancing biodiversity
it is also to suggest some ways
for putting into place reasonable
controls on light pollution
recent news reports have highlighted the
harmful effects of artificial life on
wildlife and not just bats but as my
colleague has said
insects amphibians birds mammals plants
and of course us
some of you may have heard lord deben's
recent suffolk radio interview
where he advocates reducing artificial
light in villages or actually not having
any
with greater reliance on torches
he does concede that tans need lighting
for security
he went on to say which i think is
important the pressures to urbanize the
countryside are largely antagonistic to
dealing with climate change
now this motion is really about
rural areas it is not about removing
necessary street lighting or
circumventing existing safety standards
so how do we go about doing this
two schools are suggested as a start
first as has been mentioned our
biodiversity planning documents sbd
to increase protection for wildlife
we are also preparing a design code to
reflect the new nppf's mandate to value
beauty tranquility and the natural world
the process of developing these
documents will give us ample opportunity
to consult further
with others such as the county council
wildlife organizations and community
safety groups
and to unravel some of the technical
aspects so that the resulting documents
have clear and practical application
i'm aware that the county council
which is implementing a wide-scale
large-scale led lighting replacement
program in the county
can
bring in
methods such as filters or shrouds or
dimmable lighting
which will further mitigate
the effects of particularly the white
blue color range
on
living creatures
these approaches and any added costs
would be considered within the sbd and
design code process
also i would like to see a much more
critical approach to applications for
illuminated advertising thank you which
also contribute much arguably
unnecessary light pollution in nuisance
community safety would naturally be
taken into account in measures to reduce
light pollution
there are studies however that indicate
that in rural areas lack of street
fighting may not reduce climb crime and
i believe that balance is achievable
between the wide benefits of natural
dark skies and the human desire for
safety and assurance in summary i
believe that greater weight should be
placed on local sensitivities both human
and otherwise and it is timely to review
this entire subject and add reasonable
protections against light pollution
through the means available to us thank
you
thank you california
we're now going to move to debate
councillors will only be allowed to
speak once and for three minutes
and this will be timed
uh so who would like to kick off
council mclaughlin
thank you very much indeed um i too
support lord deben in avoiding the
urbanization of our rural communities
and he like i will be horrified at the
new dare i call them belichia beacons in
oakley
has anyone heard of ockley and does
anybody know what a belichia beacon is
but it's a flashing light
and so i support what the motion is
trying to do
and
whilst a bulisha beacon in octoly might
be useful to them i'm sure the insects
don't think so thank you
thank you uh chairman i i'm more than
happy to support this
motion but they're just a couple of
points i would like to mention
we need to have a framework to decide
when and where and put on and not put on
how do you define rural and i'm not
trying to put barriers in the way but
you can
i think we all know of areas which are
in mid-suffolk which are classified as
rural but do have extensive street
lighting so there needs to be a
framework and an explanation to local
people why you may or may not put them
on and off and i absolutely understand
this better use of scare snapped
resources like pollution biodiversity
but in order to make sure the confidence
of local people is maintained
particularly those who get some
reassurance from a security community
safety point of view that street
lighting is essential i happen to live
in an area certainly where outside where
i am where there are no street lights
but just around the corner for me is a
development of one two five houses where
they had got a couple of street lights i
never quite understood why they put them
there that was some time ago so all i
would say is please can we have a
framework explain the logic why we're
doing it in order to make sure that we
do get the public on board i think
that's really really important when we
look at development so we don't get
knee-jerk reactions and a huge variation
in where we apply this thank you
chairman
[Music]
uh thank you thank you chair um i i
certainly will be supporting this motion
um
and i i would just like to i certainly i
support lord deben's um comments about
removing lighting in rural areas i
actually grew up in a village just over
the border in essex where we had no
street lights
and i was shocked when i went to a
started driving in town as to how light
it actually was and that was that was
way back you know 30 odd years ago um i
i think that we certainly need i agree
with council pass more about making sure
we get the residents on board because i
think there is a vast misconception
about uh how lighting um
actually reducing crime i think it's
just a public perception uh several
studies have uh occurred both here in
the uk and and overseas have shown that
actually dark neighborhoods do actually
reduce crime because because local
residents will notice somebody walking
about with a torch uh
whereas if it's all lit um you know i
think there have been i can't cite any
but there have certainly been studies to
show that having lights on all night
does not reduce crime in actual fact it
may even increase the amount of crime so
yes we do need some uh public awareness
about about that um
uh
you know so you know yeah no artificial
lights in villages i'm i'm happy with
that um in a rural area as well as the
biodiversity i mean a lot of our rural
areas we have um
you know depots and industrial premises
and they do seem to be having an awful
lot of light uh which is uh causing a
lot of light pollution so i will
certainly be supporting this motion
thank you
thank you chair um yes i i really
there's mine is actually a question but
um
we're not
okay
so
under the crime and disorder act
uh section 17
the council has a statutory
responsibility to consider
safety and implications in any decisions
it undertakes
in essence this must include
implementing and mitigating any
circumstances where there is reasonable
cause and concern in relation to
community safety
with regards to safety and street
lighting
whatever decision is made to change the
type of lighting for new or replacement
artificial lighting
whether in the form of street lighting
commercial or residential lighting
consideration must be given to areas
that may have the potential to commit
crimes
for example public lanes alleys
areas with a lot of wooded foliage cover
i'm saying this basically because
of the health and safety of women and
girls and to a lesser extent to men
who in areas like stone market
could
suffer
thank you
councillor matheson your turn
thank you chair yes just a couple of
points um the the
one of the this refers to street street
lighting and
um while there are a lot of streets that
are adopted by the county council
many new developments
now include quite a lot of private
driveways
and
i think that we need to
look
through our planning department
to
ensure that the right kind of lights
if necessary are put onto private
driveways
rather than
just
you know whatever's cheapest or
something
so we need to just look a little
carefully in the light of this motion
in that place in particular i think
perhaps the supplementary planning
document will um
will go there
and um the other point which might help
um counselor passmore or or counselor
brewster or
um others maybe is that i represent the
village of one house as as some of you
know
and
about 40 years ago
when they
the main um estate was being
designed and built there
the
the village the villages of the day
that were already there said well dude
we don't want we don't want street
lights we don't want street lights and
there was actually
a little referendum held
and the result of that was that they did
not want street lights and i think
somebody must have decided are you sure
because it was held twice and twice they
voted that no they didn't want and it's
interesting that the current application
for for um
20 i think it is houses
on the edge of the village and already
i'm getting emailed emails saying we
don't want street lighting on this new
bid
and that's quite interesting um and that
is the express view of
that part of the public so i think the
answer there partly is um about the
logic and the framework and all the rest
of it
is to actually ask people
thank you
councillor willem
thank you chair um
i can remember once upon a time when i
was a young engineer i was so proud of
my first road ski which included a
roundabout with the best quality street
lighting that you could imagine
but then i had a phone call from one of
the residents nearby
who was a breeder of canaries and he
said that because of the lights
his birds didn't know when to mate and
and it was a serious it was a serious
complaint and a claim against the county
council
um so if canaries don't know when to
mate presumably there's lots of other
lots of other birds that don't know when
to make
but more seriously
yeah high standards of street lighting
give very very bright light we know that
that's why they're put there
and but they also give very very dark
shadows it's the bright the contrast
between the very bright brightness and
the very dark darkness which is a
problem
um and it it helps people
who want to misbehave to hide up so i
there there there is research which
shows that
very often by having either a very low
level of street lighting or switching it
off completely that does not lead to an
increase in crime
uh and my last point is
would it not be illogical to insist on
biodiversity improvements on our new
developments
and not not insist on lighting which
would
not reduce biodiversity and i'll be
supporting the motion
counselor geek
thank you chair um just to to add some
chapter and verse to the uh great things
that have been said by everybody
a 2015 study that was published in the
journal of epidemiology and community
health found that street lights don't
prevent accidents or crime but of course
they do cost a lot of money
lighting it's been found may make you
feel safer but cambridgeshire did some
research prior to the uh to some
reduction in their street lighting which
has shown that that it's only in very
specific places where there was already
a crime hotspot that was uh made worse
by um
poor lighting only then may specific
improvements prove beneficial and and of
course all this is very short term
reduction in crime is a short-term and
localized thing even if it does happen
and you can see from the research that
it's unlikely to happen
but we'll definitely not be safer if our
lights are contributing to the
biodiversity crisis because ultimately
we can live without lights but we can't
live without pollinators so i will be
supporting the motion
thank you chair
well i'm going to sort of major on one
element which i think that we really can
achieve a difference as a council and
that's commercial development
advertising signage et cetera i do feel
sometimes as an urban member that we see
a lot of applications for advertising
signage within the town centre which are
truly awfully bright and don't actually
need to be because the town centre is
already well lit
but i would hope that we as an authority
would show the way to others in the
development of gateway 14 our planned
development there where we're planning
to develop a huge acreage
and i think we need to really take
seriously the lighting aspect of that
whilst accepting that some businesses
will operate 24 hours a day and need
lighting for
not only security but also operational
purposes i would hope that all of our
street lighting and infrastructure there
meets the very latest standard and i
think if we pass this motion today
that's something we should certainly
ensure
are there any other counselors that wish
to speak
counselor field
i was just going to point out uh
that this is not just about turning
lights off it's also about changing the
uh the nature
of the leds we're using
and
looking at graph in front of me here now
if you switch down from the sort of six
and a half thousand degrees kelvin color
temperature leads that are frequently
used for street lighting
down to the 2700 that you tend to use
at home and you call warm white usually
you get about a 50 increase in the
amount of light in the
main area of the visual spectrum and a
four to one reduction in the blue light
so overall reducing light intensity i
think is valuable
um
clearly turning lights off when you
don't need them is extremely valuable
but equally well a simple move which is
just shifting the color temperature down
also contributes substantially reducing
the hazard to in insects and not
impacting on
visibility of humans so i'll certainly
be supporting this you know for all
those reasons
right i don't see anyone else looking to
speak so
um i'll ask councillor pratt if he
wishes to add anything further
yes thank you chair so um i think you
know taking on board all the comments um
it's been a really interesting
discussion um
i think as
councillor brewster and um
has sort of mentioned um perhaps there
is there is a need for a
framework to define you know what is
rural and so on um
you know where where would be um
appropriate
to to turn the lights off
um yeah and we also there has also been
uh expressed the need to to get people
on board really and i really i really
believe that that's important
um we need to as
council madison has said ask people
whether they want street lighting if it
is going in to a planning application
for example
as there's seems to be evidence that
residents sometimes have expressed that
they don't really want it
and i think you know we just need to
sort of follow the evidence as it
emerges really in terms of
you know whether whether we really need
the street lighting in the first place
does it reduce crime
um this might be very cons context
specific depending on the environment of
course um but yeah
so so yeah i'll just um
wrap it up by saying that and thank you
very much
i will now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the electronic vote
thank you chair councillors um the to
consider the motion on notice received
from councillor pratt that item is now
showing blue please can you place your
votes thank you
i will need to take your vote
um verbally
for okay
and you can't snorton oh okay
chair we have um one vote against and 29
four
so that is carried
thank you all very much indeed um
we'll move on to
uh item 3b
this is to consider the motion on notice
received from counselor melon
counselor melon would you like to move
your motion please
yes thank you chair and um
really glad to see the the cross party
agreement on that uh previous motion and
i hope we can
get something similar on this one
the government's election bill is um
passing through its various stages in
the houses of parliament and is
currently at the committee stage
and this bill introduces a requirement
to show photo photo identification at
the polling station in order to vote
at first glance this might seem like a
good thing of course nobody wants to
encourage voter fraud we should be
stamping down on this sort of thing
and surely nobody could disagree with
proving who you are
but it's when you start to look at this
proposal in detail when you scratch the
surface that problems come to light
now we have a long and i would say very
noble tradition in this country of
resisting the compulsion to carry an
identity card around with us
i see i'm holding us holding one here
but
various governments have tried to bring
them in
to the general populace and have failed
so if there was a mandatory requirement
for photo id at an election what would
we use well there are two main documents
that have a verified photo photograph on
them and that's your driving license
and your passport which is fine
and the government has indicated that
certain other documents will also be
acceptable disabled blue badge holders
various concessionary passes and the
like
but what about the rest
who don't currently carry one of those
things
the thinking is that the local
authorities would have to issue some
kind of legitimate photo id card a
voting pass or or similar thing
and this would be to
everyone who needed one maybe or maybe
just to those who applied
you can start to see when you look at
this that immediately this becomes
problematic
there will be a cost to it and that cost
will either be to the voter
or to this council
as well as an enormous bureaucratic
burden that this authority will have to
bear
we are the authority that organizes and
delivers all forms of elections
the other point of course is that the
people who don't have a passport or a
driving license tend to be those
who don't travel abroad or own a car and
these potentially are the poorest sector
of our population
so if in order to vote we require people
to fill in a form or go to a web page or
go
you know to an office to get their
identity
identity verified
we are just putting an extra hurdle in
the way
of them expressing their democratic
rights
and the truth is we don't need anything
else to discourage people from voting
it's very disappointing but you know
levels of voter engagement are pretty
low
especially for local elections
my final point is this what's the size
of the problem how much voter fraud do
we have in this country
well the answer is very very little
and having checked with our monitoring
officer the number of cases in mid
suffolk is zero
none no reports no allegations
no charges no convictions
so i think that this council should
express our opinion
to the secretary of state and right in
opposition to this measure
i do need to amend the proposal slightly
i've been
informed that a letter should more
properly be written by the chairman
rather than the leader of the council so
that's a small amendment to the proposal
but to sum up
voter id
is an answer in search of a question
it's a very expensive and bureaucratic
sledgehammer to crack a non-existent nut
so i encourage members to support this
motion let's communicate our concern to
the secretary of state and hopefully he
will think again
thank you thank you catherine uh could i
have a second to please counselor scarf
thank you chair yes i'm very pleased to
second the motion and the slight
amendment that councilman mellon has
proposed
according to the house of commons
library probably the most controversial
measure in the elections bill 2021 to
2022 is voter id the government argues
this will improve the integrity of
elections and prevent someone's vote
being stolen otherwise known as
personation
it proposes a broad range of photo id
will be allowed including a free voter
card available to those without any
other form of id
i would suggest that even having to
apply for this free voter card may
discourage electors from exercising
their democratic right to vote
as of august 2020 one conviction and one
caution had been secured for personation
offences at elections in the whole of
2019
hardly overwhelming proof of a problem
even the electoral commission's 2019
evaluation of the voter id pilots that
were carried out across the country
found that some groups of people may
find it harder than others to show voter
id
currently it's estimated that over 2
million people do not have an acceptable
form of id
and indeed the chair of the parliament's
human rights committee
said
the government must prove that the need
for people to get a voter id does not
act as a deterrent to voting
in particular they must demonstrate an
understanding so far lacking of the
impact of these measures on marginalized
groups
and show how they plan to ensure access
to the ballot box for all
furthermore the committee said
the impact of the proposals may fall
disproportionately on some groups with
protected characteristics under human
rights law
older people and disabled people are
less likely to have voter id
and some groups such as black asian and
minority ethnic communities may be
hesitant to apply for the voter card
leave you with a question
what happens if a voter goes to vote and
forgets their id
currently you don't need to take your
polling card to go vote you just say who
you are and they check who you are on
the electoral roll and issue you with a
ballot paper
if they go to vote under the new system
and have forgotten their id
will they go home and then return or
will they just give up and not vote
so i will be supporting the motion
right
so i think we're now ready to move to
the debate uh councillors will be
allowed three minutes as usual and this
will be timed who would like to go first
hicks
thank you i'm very happy to go first if
we remember back to 2019 the
conservatives were elected with i think
a record majority and in the manifesto
was the elections bill
which is an ambitious timely set of
plans to actually ensure elections are
transparent that elections are fair and
elections are accountable
so a successful small scale
trial was
worked on and that worked extremely well
and that was to stop impersonation and
voter fraud
and actually to give improved confidence
to the election system that's what this
is about improved confidence
the bill will ban party campaigners
from handling postal votes and the
cabinet office has said to put a stop to
postal vote harvesting and make it an
offence for a person to attempt to find
out or reveal who an absent voter has
chosen to vote for
so of course anyone who doesn't have one
of the broad range of documents that's
been mentioned actually can get a voter
card through a very simple process from
their local authority i don't think
that's problematic i think that's pretty
straightforward
so i think actually at the heart of this
is about maintaining public confidence
in the elections process
and actually i think that's what this
does so i don't think it needs a first
glance or a second glance i think you
need to go back to 2019 election when
this was in the manifesto
and actually was supported nationwide by
a record result so i certainly will not
be supporting a manifesto that i think
is a retrograde step by taking the stand
that the opposition is doing
thank you
yeah thank you chair uh
yes i'll be supporting this motion
irrespective of whose
manifesto
uh the alternative mate may have been in
and and council hicks
took half of my speech
the only problem we have in public
confidence in elections
is not the way the ballot boxes operate
and the people that work at them
and the way that system works it's the
potential to harvest postal votes that's
where we have a very small issue in this
country that we need to resolve
so
to crack that
one of the ideas was to have an id card
i don't quite see how that works
does the postman then demand to see your
id card before he hands you the envelope
with your name on
do you have to then send a copy of your
id card along with your postal vote
so actually
it's not a well thought through
strategy to tackle something that we
recognize that more and more people see
the convenience of postal voting and
there is an inherent danger potential
danger within postal votes because who
is to know who signed that and sent that
back
because there's no physical check of the
person as there is at the polling booth
there's been i have to say at the
polling booth i've been going to for
a lot of years now um it's been the same
mother and daughter there each time and
i tell you there's been no skullduggery
going on there i can tell you uh because
they virtually know everyone in the
village that they've served because they
were both born there
so frankly i think a local solution
i.e the human being involved in it
that's accountable is by far the best
solution
an id card by whichever means i think is
a great step and of course what it would
end up with of course is the thin end of
a wedge
what we will end up seeing of course is
a slightly slippery government might put
in the fact that well actually what you
need to have is an up to date one yours
is out of date which i've noticed my id
for mid-southeast because that picture's
six years old i look far younger i'm
very sorry and and and to get them now
no you can't get them from needham
market it's all been moved to
peterborough so if you wouldn't mind
just going there to get your id card you
just look how it happens look what
happens in america where marginalized
voters have to turn up at a particular
time in a particular place 50 to 100
miles away to exercise their democratic
right we do not need to take any step in
that direction in this country i will
certainly be supporting the emotion
thank you chair
thank you counselor
councillor guthrie
thank you very much indeed um i was a
joint signatory on a bank account that's
recently closed i know the tellers i go
in regularly to see them
and
i just wanted the account moved to a
different
section
and i went into stone market today and
they welcomed me and said how do you do
thank you very much and i said well why
hasn't this happened
i said well we don't know where you live
i said well you do know where i live ah
but you didn't present us with a face
and an address of where you live
and
they know me from old so i had to drive
all the way back home again pick up a
document and i actually went into
ipswich today
with a document with my face and an
address on and it was security and i
don't have a problem with that so i'm i
will not be supporting this thank you
thank you councillor councillor ebern
thank you very much chair um i'd like to
make a few points if i may
um firstly four percent of the
population don't have any recognizable
id so that's four percent of people who
will have to get something sorted out um
if this goes through
and who will be sorting that out the
local authority that's
people here
secondly 87 percent of people this is
from electoral commission
research feel that voting is safe from
fraud
and that is a very very high figure as
i'm sure you'll all agree
thirdly
in this country we have very well run
elections now who runs the elections
well as a few members of staff here that
have been involved in running are very
well run elections in mid-suffolk and i
think that's a fact that you know we
should be very very proud of and nothing
needs to change in on that basis
but finally and importantly we are the
local authority that administers
elections now who is going to be paying
for a system to provide everybody who
hasn't got voter id with the correct
voter id who's going to be helping them
out who's going to be manning the phones
when somebody phones up to say oh i
don't know what i'm supposed to do i
don't have a passport i i don't drive
what do i need to do where do i get help
what forms do i fill in who's going to
process those forms who's going to pay
for the staff to process those forms
where are their staff going to come from
it's all going to land at the door of
the local authority which is mid-suffolk
so you know just from an absolute local
perspective i think this is a be a
retrograde step there's lots of things
in the elections bill that i'm sure will
go through this is one aspect of it
that needs to be changed i'd really
commend you all to vote for this
motion and i will be thank you chair
councillor morley
thank you chair
i feel a bit conflicted on this one
actually because
as a matter of general principle
i totally believe
in id
i get really frustrated
going to different places and being told
you want this piece of id or no you
can't have that bit you want this bit
even to go and get pick up a parcel from
parcel force at my local post office i
have to take my passport
and
and a bill with me
having a single
id
for me
is the obvious way
to solve
all these random bits of paper that we
have to carry around with us
and
so
personally
if i if i ruled the world
i'd have everybody microchipped but
clearly but clearly that's a different
motion
so
so i i do feel a bit
i worry about the ability of our staff
manning
polling stations
to
insist that somebody can't vote without
id or to ensure that somebody without id
cannot vote
and
but given
as councillor eben has just said there's
only four percent of our residents
who don't have
an id
that doesn't seem a very
to crack a nut type thing so
i guess i'm coming down on the side of i
don't support this i i think id is a
good thing and the only people it's
going to disenfranchise are those who
who seek to subvert our democratic
system so i'm afraid i won't be
supporting this
council
thank you chair i've listened to to both
sides of the argument on this on this
particular motion
and i'm a little bit intrigued because
we hear that the biggest problem with
our electoral system
is postal vote fraud
and yet this uh forcing people to take
id
to vote in person is surely going to
mean more people
are going to be using a postal voting
system because they haven't got their id
card or they have or they can't bother
to to apply for one
i wish i was in councillor guthrie's
lucky position
to have forgotten my id or didn't take
the id when she went to the banking
stone market to be able to jump in a car
with a driving license with no doubt a
photograph that is her id
go back home sort it all out and take
another trip into ipswich now all of
that costs money and you're actually
disenfranchising those people who don't
have a driving licence who are perhaps
in minority groups
who haven't got the id
and i'm sorry yeah for a bank account
maybe i'd make the effort and okay i'd
forgotten the idea i hadn't got the
right id one day i would make the effort
to go in again with my id another day
but voting happens on one day i've i've
taken the trouble to go to the polling
station and i haven't got my id
and and a lot of people will not go back
home and get their id and come back
again so we're going to have less people
voting
in our elections which is not what we
want and i think because of the hassle
of getting an id card more people are
going to say well you don't need an id
card to do a postal vote i'll do a
postal vote and yet so this solution of
having id cards is not going to help us
in our the biggest problem with the
fraud
in elections which is postal voting and
and i completely understand councillor
morley's position about wouldn't it be
wonderful if we just had a single id
card that's not what we're talking about
it'll be yet another id card
uh and okay i've got a passport i don't
have a driving license i'm not lucky
enough to be eligible to have a driving
licence when my passport expires i'm not
likely to be traveling abroad i probably
won't have a apart i get renew my
passport and then i'll have to apply for
an id card so maybe i'm one of the four
percent but i cannot see that a solution
or the the problem of that we have with
our electoral system at the moment is
going to be solved by having an id card
so i will be supporting this motion
council turner
um as a matter of principle i believe
this is quite frankly the thinner thin
edge of the wedge
um
which could lead i believe to national
identity cards something which certainly
the liberal democrats have campaigned
against
many years ago when there was a
suggestion that the council of the
country would bring in id cards
i also think it's a real shame
that as a result of maybe
in
a much more urban
situation
there have been a few instances
where
the local authority has had to
investigate
where id fraud
or similar has taken place but i do not
believe that this is a time that we
should be taking on
a system
which completely discriminates against a
significant
part of the population and i certainly
will be supporting this motion thank you
but council carter
get right button eventually there we go
um
well i will be supporting this despite
having my own conflicts with sharing uh
councillor wally's uh
that i would be in favor of a if they
had microchips as well especially if it
was the government funded free to a
consumer and that would just be able to
show you microchip to go and freedom of
movement but that's unfortunately not
the case
um
this actually came up in a disability
meeting quite recently
regards members of learning disability
who
do not have meta forms of id
and find it either too
complicated um
or would be put off to apply
this also came up in a meeting regards
uh the windrush scandal however
the
proportion of voters who
are less likely to apply for id out of
fear am i actually of reprisal of
actually uh being asked to leave the
country
which
you could argue a point
both ways and this but
i'm all in favor of
democracy i'm all in favor of people
being able to go out and have a vote
i'm in favor of people having
more of a voice and feeling empowered to
vote
and not
feeling more marginalized and less
likely to do so
and we are finding an increase of people
who are
applying for
postal voting
part of it due to a recovered situation
not wanting to go a house
this doesn't solve
poster voting fraud
this doesn't
prevent
it being collected
so we're likely to have an increase of
people going for postal voting
we won't have any solutions about their
votes being
harvested we're increasing yet another
loop to jump through
so
where is the benefit to us we're causing
more hassle and
we're not getting any benefit from it so
i'm certainly in favor of this motion
and more solutions would be looked at in
favor
of you
thank you
i think i will
be supporting this motion
i i sometimes wonder in a in a world
where
google can
ask me
or tell me which particular cafe i was
in in the middle of malta four years ago
whether i'm being a bit sensitive to
people knowing
who i am and where i am
but nevertheless i guess i was always
told that one of the things that's that
separated
england the uk from
many countries in europe
was that we don't have id cards
policemen do not have the right to
demand they know who you are and what
you're doing whenever they tumble across
you in the street
and that this is a bit of a
move in that general direction
a direction that perhaps
wouldn't be too worrying at the moment
but there's always the risk of less
benign governments in the future
you know currently um
whatever we might think about the
particular incumbents at the moment
they're certainly not people of evil
intent
intending to control us the way
uh perhaps we've been seeing on tv in
that program ridley road that's common
at the moment you know they're not a
british
nazi party and we all hope that we'll
never move in that direction
but i personally think we have to be
very careful about putting in
this former's id as a principle
it also as many speakers have said
impacts in the case of elections
particularly on people who are
disadvantages disadvantages who don't
have current ids so it's disgrading that
portion of the population
from voting persuading them they're more
detached whereas i think council hicks
implied that what we want to do is
increase confidence
increasing the numbers of people who
believe in the in the democratic system
so i think you know taking all those
things in in
in combination particularly also with
the evidence from 2019 elections where
there were
eight people who were
cautioned by the police or prosecuted
only one of those was actually for
impersonation
um several were
falsifying balanced papers
um one was first
attempting to steal a ballot box because
the person wasn't being allowed to vote
so something that this
certainly would not solve i think taking
all those things together my view is
that
this is a really bad idea we should
support the motion we should not move
towards
formal ids in this way in the uk
thank you
thank you council of war boys
in support of the motion
i think the notion of producing
voter id is very much a solution
a very expensive solution in search of a
problem
in 2019 there were 34 allegations of
voter fraud
this was
58 million votes cast without any
allegations
the questions have arisen about postal
valleys
uh which is a separate issue and again
having voter ids will not necessarily
produce a solution
in europe id cards are mandatory
everybody has one
they get them at an early age they are
free or very low cost with a vote with
an id card you can travel throughout
europe access
social services
and
they allow freedom of movement
but in the uk we do not have mandatory
id cards
passports are expensive
this is a bit out of date but in the
2011 census nine and a half million
people do not have a passport
nine million people do not have a
driving licence
one 1.3 million do not have a bank
account so they fell at that
early stage of having to provide id or
going through the rigmarole
northern ireland as a free electoral id
card but as everyone is well aware
northern ireland is
has got a history of a necessity
of
ensuring voter ids
public opinion
appalled by the electoral commission 87
percent
said voting is safe
from fraud and abuse
i do believe
uh this is my feeling that
flagging up the necessity
for voter id
is actually gaslighting our electoral
system i think there are threats to our
democratic system but it's not the
necessity for voter id
i think we do need to look at the way
political parties are funded
how political parties spend their funds
how political parties misinform the
electorate
the impact of social media
on
the electoral system the manipulation of
social media
by conservative parties so
i do not think
the necessity for voter id is actually a
threat to our electoral system
uh it's already mentioned that four
percent of the population do not have
any recognizable form of id
i believe forcing people to have
voter id will actually disenfranchise
a significant proportion of our people
thank you thank you councillor
councillor geek
thank you chair um
i would like to back up what councillor
warboy says and address really
councillor hicks's views about public
confidence in the electoral system the
electoral commission research that
councillor warboys referred to shows
that public confidence in the running of
elections is as high as they have ever
found in all their years of research and
in fact in the last year up until 2021
uh there has been a large drop in the
public's perception of electoral for
fraud as a problem in the uk now the
electoral commission point out that
because election fraud almost never
happens most people have no direct
experience of it and they suggest that
it might be stories in the media that
have a notable effect on perceptions so
perhaps counselor hicks might think
about what he's reading and whether it's
backed up by research but as councillor
warboys says there is a continues to be
you say the electoral commission a
negative trend in the public's
perception of the transparency of party
and campaigner finance and that's really
the problem of confidence where the
money comes from to fund political
parties and individual politicians now
house builders gave nearly a million
pounds to the conservatives in just the
first quarter of this year um
so
you you do have to follow the money qui
bono
i don't think compulsory id cards will
help this
and in common with many others on this
side of the chamber i really don't like
the idea of compulsory identification
papers i don't like the idea that we
could be stopped and asked for our id
anywhere
i must just be much more of a
libertarian than those on the other side
of the chamber
so i will be voting for the motion thank
you
thank you counselor
counselor whitehead
thank you chairman um well i don't
believe we should ever live in a state
where officials and bureaucrats
routinely demand
show me your papers as we go about our
daily lives
but voting is a privilege it's a process
we should cherish and strengthen
not weaken and dilute
by allowing any potential for abuse
those of us who've attended election
counts were aware of how meticulous
is the process of verifying the ballot
and the care and attention that our
council staff take
during the whole process through to the
declaration of the electoral result
now putting aside the issue about postal
voting and that's something i'd be happy
debating uh in this chamber another time
to me the only weakness in the whole
system that i've observed it is that
anyone can turn up to voting station be
handed a ballot paper
as though staffing the voting station
must accept who the person in front of
them claims to be without any proof
being requested
now i personally would have no problem
whatsoever the requirement to show my
own id when i go to vote
and i'd feel more comfortable with the
integrity of the voting process
nationwide
if all of us had to do otherwise and so
for that reason i can't support the
basic premise of this motion thank you
i'm sorry
point of information
voting is not a privilege
voting is a right
thank you
does any other council wish to make a
comment
in this debate
okay um i'd like to say a few words um
i i can understand the concerns that are
expressed by
councillor mellon and others
about voter id
but actually
in the natural
walk of life
we are requested
to present id for many instances for
example as councillor guthrie uh
mentioned to to open a bank account i've
just been through the very same process
myself and even though it was an online
bank account i had to go through all the
usual loops of address photo photograph
and so on to get the account established
which is all well and good and you could
understand why
they would want to to have that uh from
a security perspective and anti-money
laundering and so forth
and and there are other instances where
you do not have to leave by by law to
produce id but id is requested and for
very good reason for example when you go
to register for a gp
and um you could understand why a gp
would want to be sure of who you are
in in terms of the treatment he's going
to deliver um
on an ongoing basis
so
i think
i i i i have a problem with councilman
mellon's motion
from some from those perspectives and
i'm also uh
conscious of the fact that
the right to vote
is something that has been fought for
over several
centuries in this country and beyond
for which people have actually given
their lives and gone to prison
and every right in my view
has a responsibility attached to it
and i think that responsibility in this
particular instance is that if you're
going to go and vote then you ought to
be able to
it ought to be able to be proven that
you are the person you say you are
and and that's why for example other
countries have introduced id voting
cards or i have a generic id i mean i
lived in the united states for a while
and i had to have an id
for various purposes including the
health service and so on so
i think when you look at it in the round
this idea of promoting
an id for voting seems quite sensible to
me and i think that that we should
not support this motion because it's not
taking that responsibility
as
well as it should be because um
we want to be able to guard our
democracy and voting is one of them and
we should make sure that it's done in
the safest most secure way possible
and that's all i have to say on that
um so with that um council mellon do you
want to wish
anything
thank you chair um
so mr chairman you you'll be well aware
that elections are won and lost by a
very few votes occasionally
and sometimes not just one ward
but a whole district can be hung
on the basis of a few notes so it's
really important
that we do nothing to undermine the
confidence
that we have in our electoral electoral
system
and we actually know that the the
current public confidence is high the
electoral commission research shows it
well over 80 percent of all the
different measures that they measured
but this could take a serious knock
if we implemented this measure and
didn't do it well
and our hard-pressed staff at a polling
station
looking at id does this really look like
the person the picture taken up to 10
years ago
do we really want to put our staff
through that
and then
undermine the confidence in the result
especially when things are so close in
this area
if i can just sum up the arguments
against this measure and in favor of the
motion
firstly the bureaucratic burden of
implementing mandatory voter id will
fall on this authority
secondly the effect of this measure may
well be an impediment to those who don't
don't currently hold an approved form of
photo id it would put them off voting
and thirdly
the level of voter fraud is
extraordinarily low
this is not a big problem
there are much bigger problems in the
system the fact that nine million people
are missing from the electoral roll
so can i encourage councillors
to use your vote i know you're going to
have to have id to vote
in this occasion
but to vote against uh mandatory voter
id at the polling station and in for
this motion thank you very much
thank you councillor
i will now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the electronic vote
thank you chair councillors if you wish
to tab down you will see the motion on
notice received from councilman mellon
please can you cast your votes it's now
showing in blue
okay
as that is 15 4 and 15 against so chair
i i will ask you do you want to exercise
your casting vote
i will yes and that will be against okay
so that motion is lost then chair
thank you um so uh please note that the
uh date of the next meeting will be
thursday the 25th of november at 5 30
p.m and i now close the meeting at 17
12.
please remember sorry i'm going back the
the vote was
late coming through
and because councillor otton voted
manually the vote was actually 16 4 and
14 against so that was actually carried
[Applause]
sorry thank you all
you